what is up guys it is Tuesday and that
means it's the gray area with myself
Sarah Garvey and the woman who currently
owns your algorithm owns your explore
page and owned your for you fan page it
is just plenty things thank you Sarah
indeed we have a good show for you today
we are going to be talking about dating
apps and whether or not they are ruining
dating or help in dating but
before we even get started tell them
if you have watched two or more of our
videos and you have not subscribed then
we have what power beef what do we have
beef exactly so you better get doing
that right now over to you pal okay guys
a couple announcements before we start
the show the first thing is that we have
two clips channels the first is Pearl
daily and the second is just pearly
Clips make sure you subscribe to both of
those
um also guys we have four membership
tiers the first lets you be a part of
the live chat the second you get behind
the scenes blogs and you get to be a
part of our Discord the third tier you
connect with me on social media
um oh my gosh guy in the fourth tier you
get a one-on-one called me once a month
um usually for the social media one
um you guys get to follow me on
Instagram and I follow back and then you
can message me but the problem is guys I
just got banned on Instagram you got
canceled yeah yeah so um I officially
don't have an Instagram
um well my old one but I have a new
Instagram it's just pearly things one I
mean when they count to you is that like
a Rites of Passage
is that like like in these days and
times that mean that you're doing
something good if you get canceled well
I probably didn't need to call her a
whale
yeah as a matter of fact why did you get
canceled well at which time this one on
Instagram yeah okay it was this girl
okay she could have been lovely but I
did not take it that way because she
started it she had a video calling me
ugly now if you call me ugly I feel like
I can retaliate I mean that's fake I
started it so I put who would you rather
smash me or her and I put a poem what
did people say I mean look it I mean she
was a hefty lady
so I was just like if I'm ugly what are
you and so then she responded was like
you're so insecure and then I I shared
that and just put a whale emoji I mean
that's a beautiful Majestic creature so
the world Emoji got you canceled yeah I
think that might have been what did it
but it's like but you'll be back well I
have um it's just pearly things one
there you go so now you guys can go
follow that please I only have like 10
followers so please yeah like nine or
ten followers please get me to a
thousand
um also guys go follow my first second
third and fourth Tick Tock got banned so
go follow just probably things five and
just probably think six
um and thank you guys for 650 000 Subs I
think 650 000. yeah yeah that's the road
to a million now seriously yeah our goal
I I don't know if we'll hit it so I'm a
little nervous to say this but it'd be
really cool if we could hit a million by
New Year's or by like or by Valentine's
Day so if you guys want to subscribe
feel free
right
we have some guests in the in the
building today a couple familiar faces a
couple of familiar faces we have so what
we're gonna do we're gonna go around and
can you introduce yourselves and give us
your name your age and relationship
status and a fun fact about you we'll
start with you over there Mr red
um obviously Eddie from the domino
effect she's not know me I've been here
quite a few times age I'm 28 what are
you saying fun fact
um I know no no no no no don't try and
wash your relationship status oh so uh
um now I'm single okay and fun fact is
anatomy oh that is fun wow
yeah commits though okay next love that
uh uh hi I'm Lola I'm 29.
I'm in a relationship fun fact
[Music]
I don't know how to knit that's not very
fun is it
um
[Music]
I am in a
relating things maybe that's maybe
that's a fun fact or an interesting
perspective oh okay that's an
interesting one okay next
um I'm Claire I'm 32 and I'm single and
a fun fact
um I I taught myself calligraphy
um fancy writing basically okay for
those that don't know nice
all right then well let's get into it
can I do a shout out to house Cheryl L
for 300 three 100 super chats this man
what from the jump yeah from the jump oh
shout out I'm just gonna read this
because we haven't even started the show
Pearl's archetypes be priest sales
um Mercantile trade and space orbiting
EG gravity how different has different
properties in different states touched
touched his calling a few times probably
yachting he doesn't exist on land mama
cleans up after the hubby because she is
the master administrator Mama's love
language equals quality time they pray
together Papa's active service maybe a
daily meal from fresh cup to the day
equals moms on the job King Richie's
archetype school teacher priest sorry
that was me
um architecture the mines Temple um KR
is also a walking lie detector another
story this one boss girl Felicia was
naturally bossy today because Ned was a
new she went up she oh my gosh this is
so long this is random yeah she went up
and down him and seized that he had
pent-up aggression so she rolled up her
cloth and helped out the little fella
watch my eyes you cute Ting she bossed
um happy birthday
um her hair is always fire nice voice
too my uncle has a piano he has an
Olympic touch on him he's been Aussie
pronounced Ozzy of the Year BT dubs but
not enough about me long live and
prosper um Chad Carlo I am beef people
but that sounded like gibberish I'm not
gonna lie to you but shout out you okay
oh my gosh um so let's get started um
we're going to talk about dating apps
and whether it's ruining Dayton or not
folks um first of all first question
is anyone here on a dating app and
has it been a negative or a positive
experience for you
when you see on a dating app do you mean
like actively using it to find something
or just like you you just happen to be
you just have you have it downloaded
which one is it I mean you're using it
you're active on it yeah
um now I'm not active on the dating apps
but um depending on the outcome you're
looking for
they're definitely beneficial depending
on the outcome you're looking for that's
the key
do you think they're a bit more
beneficial for men than the other women
because you sounded like you you've had
like good time on dating
I'm not gonna lie um the dating apps
make things a lot more simplistic again
depending on what your outcome is like
and I think different dating apps
um will obviously lead to different
outcomes for people so I think two of
the more prominent ones is probably
hinge and Tinder that Tinder people know
today that Tinder is basically the sex
app I'd say hinge probably has a bit
more fruitful prospects for people
looking for a long-term relationship
however
again it's another place to go and have
fun if you're if you're a guy but also
for a girl I believe obviously at the
end of the day it's one that comes I'm
sleeping with women to get what I mean
so if if the girls are out there having
fun on those dating apps as well then I
guess it's beneficial for both again
depending on what you're looking for
okay
no I've only ever used dating apps twice
I've been on two dates in total from
those apps that I've used were there
good dates
no not particularly and it wasn't that I
wanted to do it it was more like you
know your friends convinced you like
I'll try this out so I'm like okay I'll
try but it was not really for me why not
um I'm more of a Vibes person so I
prefer the old school you meet someone
you get you feel their energy and then
therefore you see if you're gonna be
friends with them or you want to date or
you're attracted to them I feel like
people going for an Argos catalog of
faces yeah that's also based on people's
Aesthetics not necessarily what the
person's liking because that's not my
first thing that I go for when I'm
looking to date or be with someone
therefore it's not I don't feel like I
get much from looking at people's you
said that you were in like a female
relationship so did you go on the dating
app for both male and female or just
female I always go on for both okay yeah
which I think before you can do that on
apps you had to be one or the other but
um yeah I've the both dates I went on
with guys one was from Tinder he was a
hatfish
um it was just a bit boring like he was
actually lovely guy sorry I don't what
happened oh that's that's like when a
guy takes up like he let's say he's an
eight but he took off his hat now he's a
five now he's got a receiving hairline
oh gosh are you serious it wasn't that
deep but I just thought it was funny
because I'd heard someone use the
terminology before and I was like okay
why did you take this why was he
different when he so hang on let me get
this straight so you were on the app
yeah right and what on the picture he
had his hat on I yeah or I didn't clock
all his pictures he was wearing the
house he was wearing the Hat in all the
pictures well obviously I don't frequent
dating sites so I didn't I didn't
realize he was good looking right then
when I met him yeah which is fine it was
just yeah and then when you met him he
took his hat off yeah he had really bad
receiving hairline
it wasn't that deep but because as I
said it's not all about Aesthetics but
it shows you that people can portray
themselves online as something that
they're not and if you meet people in
person you're more likely to get a Vibe
about the person then I mean even for
like writing a profile the kind of
person I am people might see me and
assume I'm this well that way but I'm
actually so many other things there's
not enough bio to write how you are as a
person I don't feel so you're more
likely to accept his his receding
hairline if you met him in person over
it was just like it's just an attraction
thing so I didn't find him as attractive
so um so for me and then the fact that
his energy wasn't really he was nice but
our energies didn't match it just felt
like it wasn't really it was a bit of a
waste of time so that was the first one
um yeah so okay are you on a date now uh
I have one downloaded but I'm not really
active on it if I'm honest I don't
really it's not ideal I like meeting
people in person like you say because
you get you get like a lot more from
them than just texting
um I think my situation I don't really
go out so I don't really meet anyone you
know that and unless it's like on now I
don't I don't really meet people I don't
go out you know so it's not it's not
really
So when you say you don't go out does
that mean wouldn't dating apps be ideal
for you yeah that's what I'm saying they
are ideal but they're just long and
because it's so quick and because my
situation I don't need to get much free
time so you've got to keep talking to
these people sometimes a couple of weeks
do you see what I mean before I'm free
so the chances of them still talking to
me that when it's so quick and it's just
it's just a bit longer I'm not the
biggest fan of it if I'm honest
the thing is right I'm of a different
generation okay and when I was growing
up to me dating apps
was basically the Lonely Hearts column
yeah 100 like black we do have like
Lonely Hearts column newspapers so when
I look at dating apps I'm like are
people really that lonely that they've
got to go to uh
insecure I don't sorry buddy I'm curious
um has any of you ever had a
relationship develop from a dating app
like a long-term one no no
no so I I'm I've never I've never been
on it I've never been on a dating app
okay I've never been on one time but I
have to add though I also use the dating
apps for recruitment purposes as well
because that's a great place to meet
people who are yeah it's a network as
well so you know him
so I think the difference with when I
first when I used Tinder that was like
my friends convinced me I'd gone for a
breakup just try and go on a date okay
cool didn't like it right and that was
fine hinge I found was more
um something that I'd find more
beneficial for me because you get more
of a profile about the person it asks
you are you a smoker do you like raving
do you go out do you have any pets these
are like it's more like a social profile
right and people can ask questions so
you get more of a flavor for the person
so with a different dating apps like
different different purposes different
purposes and I think it's about being
clear about what you're trying to get
out of the situation previously if like
you said you're old school people used
to date or Court in order to get married
and be in stable long-term relationships
right now people are more is it
something short term you want a day you
want to friends with benefit you want a
sugar daddy you want a husband like
people are not clear about what it is
they're seeking therefore
it's that I think that's why apps are
more prevalent now that's why you're
saying Eddie's saying that obviously
people go on apps and it's for if it's
Tinder maybe it's just a sexual thing
it's not necessarily for long term so
different apps come with different
nuances people are seek an arrangement
because I want to Sugar Daddy what do
you guys think of this stat
on popular dating apps Tinder
women swipe right 14 of the time where
men swipe right 46 percent of the time
it doesn't surprise me yeah so surprised
so swiping right means that yeah that's
a yes you've liked and then if the
person swipes right as well then you get
a match well then I I basically think I
think that's that's hypergamy on
steroids isn't it like I've always said
like hypergamy right now as I'm steroids
and I think women are looking for the
the literal ideal man which is probably
why they swipe right 14 of the time men
uh we're not that picky a lot of the
time like it was like ah she looks okay
it's fine I think it's a cheat code it's
a cheat code for one for the woman to to
get access to the type of man that she
deserves whereas for a guy it's just
easy to
to do the numbers game where I can I can
try and get as much as possible as much
volume as possible in the shortest time
that I can
um
so yeah people people getting lost in it
in reality it's like a picking mix now
who do you think it's more beneficial
for um an average woman or a top tier
man who gets more benefit out of a
dating app it's definitely a top tier
man top tier but at the same time the
benefit the benefit is is easy at fifth
to fix it I think it's what what dating
apps do is it plays into a man's
biological imperative which is just to
like scatter his seed tastes like you
get far more access to to women if
you're a Gaba certain caliber as we know
women only swipe right a small minority
of the time but if you're able to
portray enough of the characteristics
that women are are into then you have a
massive access to a massive pool of
women that's just easy to slay like look
at them to the Tinder Swindle as a
perfect example yeah it is so there is
um someone in the chat said 60 of
married people used to meet at work in
the U.S and now 60 of married people
meet on dating apps that is actually
crazy
sign of the times though isn't it I
suppose people are busy now it's just
easier to but what's worse with that is
that I think the people would meet on
dating apps only last an average of like
five years in a marriage whereas people
who meet at work it's an average of 10
or more yeah but do people go once it's
like five is around the average length
of a marriage yeah it's like five they
start that they get divorced by seven
it's like do people go on dating apps or
find long-term relationships do you guys
think yes some people do I know one of
my friends got married and they've got
two kids they they met on a dating app
what what app was it do you know it was
Tinder really yeah it was but she it was
they had they had messy oh don't because
it's our business but it yeah it was we
don't know yeah I know but still she um
yeah there was Tinder that they they had
met on
I think women would probably be way more
likely to look for something more
serious
um than men would what I've noticed that
hinge do is that you have a section
where you can say are you like are you
looking for a long-term relationship or
short-term yeah relationship the weird
thing about it is you will get a lot of
girls saying figuring out dating goals
or looking for short-term relationships
and I think that's quite interesting in
terms of what women Aspire for
um what they're looking for long term
because the reason why I'm asking like
has it ruined dating like
as it made as it made human interaction
um a little bit more what we're looking
for frivolous like it's not it's not as
you know there's no meaning behind the
behind the connection it it it's it's
it's belittled to what human interaction
means because it it takes away a lot of
the necessary things that would make a
meaningful interaction because now it's
a case of like I said it's a picking mix
whereas before the guy who had the dead
hairline might have been a guy who was
appealing based on how he came across
because he'd learned how to communicate
with other people whether it's now these
guys are Savvy on texting and then in
person they're just [ __ ] yeah right yeah
so you've they've lost the importance of
active communication and that affects
long-term situations I agree with that I
think it's a sign of the times because
we're losing human interaction that's
such a fast rate isn't actually scary so
we're doing so much we're looking at so
much time based on screen and you know
even when you go to the shops you no
longer go into a cashier you're using a
machine right we're getting so into like
losing that I think even if you look at
the younger generation they don't even
know how to effectively communicate it
or have manners or hold a conversation
that is Meaningful because everything's
so based on internet and I also think
that that's set a standard or a
precedent that people are now very
insecure because people are not really
living in their truth so they're looking
at this than the other and then they're
basing their expectations as you're
saying about women having a high
expectation of this perfect man but does
that even exist but you're basing it on
something that's false pretenses because
you've seen on the Internet influencers
or models or do you see what I mean so
when we're looking at these things
people are then setting standards when I
don't think half those people are even
real so that's what that's done and
that's the interesting thing I think
with with apps like Tinder and hinge it
gives women the false perception that
they can that they're a higher value
than what they are oh yeah because
having access to a certain caliber of
men even just a conversation
to a lot of women to lose them into
thinking that this is the type of man
that I can get and this is what I'm
worth and then they end up sleeping this
guy but the reality is you know a woman
is judged with the man that she can keep
not by who she sleeps with
um so I think dating apps actually
delude them into thinking that they have
a higher value than what they're
actually worth because when you say that
it's because like I've said before
um women have a hard time
differentiating between the certain
types of attention so if if a woman gets
attention she gets attention she loves
it but there are certain men that will
give you attention because they want to
smash 100 right and a certain amount
they give you attention because they
want to make you you know they're long
term and I think
um the reason why I'm asking that has it
ruined it because I'm just like women
are getting
loads of attention constantly on these
apps right and I think it's warping
their sense of reality do you know what
confuses me so like I I used to be on
dating apps I don't use them anymore but
this is just like from what I when I
used to use them and I remember speaking
to one girl on on the stating up and
she was like um
she was a um a twerk teacher
as you can imagine her her profile was
this full field of just booty I've seen
cheeks and I'm like yeah all right cool
so I've slid in there drop a little bar
here and there so now me and her talking
I've met this girl and she was then
upset
it's like why do guys always look at me
for one thing because you portrayed that
yeah as a twerking teacher not just a
twerking if you see what home girl was
wearing not alone it was a Madness yeah
and obviously
when I've seen her
it was a similar situation yeah do you
know what I mean so she saw her and her
cheeks were out cheeks was out and I was
thinking yeah no they waited
so she would she and obviously me I like
to have conversations obviously the way
we do podcasting we just like to talk
and understand your way of thinking
right so she's complaining why do men
always always see me for one thing and
you know why can't a guy just Overlook
my assets and just focus on me
but I'm just like don't you understand
that what you're portraying is what
we're gonna act upon well I've always
said everything is sales in this life
everything you sell so and people are
going to ask you
um before you even before you even open
your mouth people are looking at you and
they're and they're wondering what
you're selling right and so if you see
constantly cheeks breasts
skimpy clothes you're gonna be like okay
I can see what she's selling so people
who say to themselves or say to you or
me and say oh why do guys only see me as
flesh It's like because well that's what
you're selling but the thing is it's
gone it's just interesting because
they'll take a twerking class before
they take a cooking class right relax
it's like you it's like you want to be
valued for something else but what have
you done to be valued for something else
I agree with that is it my
responsibility to see any different than
how you portray yourself of course not
because why should I see any differently
if you're gonna give me a certain
product which is what you're
representing right now right why do I
have to have the responsibility to see
any different than what you're giving me
that doesn't make no sense do you think
it's the same for guys do you think that
if a guy is like constantly got like his
top off and his app showing in his chest
showing do you think a guy feels the
same way like oh my God why are they
only viewing me for what I look like no
I think that guys do that because they
want to be viewed as that kind of Mel
that is yeah going out and he's that guy
is because they want to show you that
they're out there to they're that guy
they're the study guide they're going to
sleep with all the women and they're not
showing you that they want to be your
husband what's feminine it's like I
think it's kind of feminine when guys
take a lot of selfies and they're super
into appear like I don't know so a guy
topless on on the Internet is like it's
feminine you say I I'm not a fan of like
the shirtless pictures
though that's the difference they I
think they think that we like that and
you get that a lot in exactly the same
as on day and apps you get a lot of men
with kids so you're looking at these
kids there's nothing over their face
that's just mad that it's just
unbelievable that they're happy and in
their head I'm sure they think the women
are going to love this like they're
gonna do oh women do but I'm sorry if
you're a d if you've got a bit of
something about you you're looking at a
man that's got a kid their face out
there I don't look at that and think oh
he's good
no yeah I've got some but I wouldn't put
his face on the [ __ ] dating app but
the thing is women tend to lack that
stuff yeah it's a sign of pre-selection
so if a guy has a kid it signals to a
woman that someone else has someone yeah
I get that it's just it's just too much
I feel like men if a guys commonly do
something it's probably because it works
100
so as much as I say like oh you know I'm
not a big fan of the shirtless selfies
they do it often it probably and it
works I wonder what saw women they're
attracting by doing that do you see what
I mean do they care
so I don't mean I do care but in the
long term if that's what they're used to
then when they want to come and look for
a partner and they've just been used to
getting their top off and getting some
action and they're going to be confused
I mean I think I think if they didn't
like the quality of girls they got
they'd probably stop doing it but it's
again we're going back to the not
looking for long-term Solutions they're
not looking for long-term relationship
some people are seeking instant
gratification
relationships and long term this is
something interesting I'm trying to find
a torsa put in the chat when you're
talking about women that put short-term
on their profile she says that's a
mating strategy so she can get access to
the guys that are looking for short term
right so she's saying like it's the same
thing when guys say they want a
relationship when they just want
something short oh okay because that's
going to attract them yeah so it's like
a mating strategy okay so it's like okay
I say short term yeah but I really want
something at the momentum like I'm
trying to lock him down right it's like
being ambiguous it's like the ones that
say figuring out dating goals I just
want to see where it goes like what do
you think a matter to do with that
information I mean for me do you think
women would do it if it didn't work do
what do that I I'm I don't know like
could we apply the same logic and say
like women do that because it works I
think no it must do because again it
starts the conversation with the guys
they're probably interested in but the
reality is is
is the outcome by putting that the best
outcome for you and often the answer is
no but this is what I hate because in
that scenario women would then play the
victim like oh my God he did this and
they did that but it's like
you set the the foundations on on a
foreign
and it's like well if you are
put in that kind of stuff as your on
your profile right you're gonna attract
a certain type of man you're going to
attract if you attract trash around you
all the time and there's probably
something wrong with you yeah and I
don't think that's controversial either
but women it's like I don't understand
why it's so okay to hate men
I was actually going to pull that up why
not because part of what you'll see a
lot on hinge is gone because on hinge
you can have the there's a question you
can answer the question yourself so some
of them will say I'm a 10 Baht and then
put the butt wherever the Butters but
one of the questions I often see is
prove to me that and then you will hear
the answer for the girl is men aren't
trash or all men aren't [ __ ] or things
along those lines just blatant misandry
but it plays the plate of His Banner I'd
love to see if a man said that prove to
me so you're saying that in these dating
apps um miss Andrew is just like it's
normal it's very normal like you will
see on a lot of women's profiles but
it's misogyny then this is normal well I
can't I can't see the guy's side so I
can only assume that
um they'll probably get canceled or that
you can report them I'm sure women will
do they're probably not answering on
hinge you don't have to answer all of
the questions so you you can make your
profiles like
long or short as you want and I don't
think the guys are answering all of
those long do you know what I mean
instead of keeping it basic I'm curious
have you guys
um ever had a relationship start from
being approached in person
yeah yeah
cold yeah cold approach yeah
yeah okay what like um yeah relationship
is not a relationship no no no you have
wasn't approaching a woman yeah yeah
come on man's got so speed
but that's the thing like do you do you
guys prefer that
interaction that human interaction or do
or do you prefer the interaction via the
screen yeah human yeah but the thing is
people say that but there's less
interaction via humans and more via the
screen the generation that as well it's
a different generation right now I find
that I've got Snapchat I'm not really on
Snapchat like that I've got Snapchat
ages ago because someone was saying it's
true that when certain things happen in
the world if you go on the map and then
you look at like the hot spots you can
see what's going on in real life do you
see what I mean like that's why I like
it for that aspect but of course when
you've got that profile but people use
like Instagram and Snapchat as online
dating it's just a different sort of
just different sort of thing Instagram's
the biggest you know what's what's
interesting for me because
I've I've seen people say that they fell
in love with somebody right
from another place
on a screen they've never met the person
in real life like I so funny I knew this
girl
um previously not now
um
previously who had like a boyfriend
quote unquote a boyfriend that she'd
never ever met in person catfish in
there if you know it's watching no no no
no I'm not saying she's a catfish but
that that is that thing yeah but I I'm
finding it hard to understand how you
have a quote-unquote boyfriend yeah when
you've never met them in person and that
is a world where we're moving into
because people romanticize the idea of
this because you see what screens allow
you to do is it allows you to fill in
the gaps so a lot of people will see
these guys online and you're not getting
the full story so it gives and if you
are really attracted to the game then it
allows you to say you know what I'm
going to fill in the gaps with what I
want in the ideal man so it's all a form
of projection this is what I want from a
man he's got the looks already he talks
to me I'm Gonna Fill in the rest of the
gaps which are what what what all the
gaps he's a nice guy he probably loves
me he's probably selling a dream over
the phone like because I can't wait to
see you probably lives in France
somewhere yeah see what I mean literally
just sending her effort than it's worth
for the guy like you got to talk to her
for months then you've got to think what
type of guys he has got that kind of
time to yeah to do that and and that's
that's the thing about the screen going
that far like why only doing it closer
why has he got to go because I think
it's I think it's easier to sell women a
dream over a screen 100 it's not it's
not easy to sell a guy a guy will
interact with a woman via the screen in
but a woman will actually get literally
like emotionally involved literally
through words on a screen do you know
what I mean I think like the the the way
in which it's quite easy to sell women a
dream
um goes back to you know Disney movies
and rom-coms and all this kind of women
can see things on a screen and fall in
love with it and fall in love with an
idea yeah it's the fact because women
will always fall in love with what they
hear whilst men will fall in love what
they see right so it's easy to for a man
it's easy to have that kind of lustful
look for this beautiful woman but you
know because men are forced to have to
live in reality so you know this ain't
real you know that you know what this is
a fun interaction for what it is right
now but it's probably not going to go
anywhere I don't really care what the
situation is but for that woman you're
allowing her to live within a fairy tale
or you're feeding into that delusional
bubble that most women live in nowadays
it's like you know like that Disney
fairy tale the outcomes you know I'm
gonna meet my Prince Charm and he's
gonna fly over and we're gonna go we're
gonna have a great time
guys I have a crazy question torsha you
are killing it right now is it wrong for
a man to report fraud after a date with
a woman who didn't disclose that she was
trans
oh my God
on Michelle that's not a woman there you
go yeah it's fruitless fruit could you
argue that that's also if anything
sexual happens that that's sexual or s-a
yes yes yes 100 if if I've gone into a
situation thinking I'm going to this
situation thinking that's a woman and
there's a sexual like a biological woman
yeah a biological woman and there's a
sexual aspect to that interaction yes
that that is not only is that sa that's
to me that's Criminal what do you guys
think ladies
it's a mad situation um
Madness your bisexual of how like how
does it
um yeah I'm bisexual I've Got Friends
from the trans Community none that would
not disclose stuff but that to me is
wild it's unfair because obviously if
you're someone already in the LGBT
community then you're gonna be you may
be more open-minded to these things but
you need to disclose I think it's
important it'll be like someone not
disclosing they've got a whole family or
a wife or these are core things that
need to be discussed
um especially if you're straight so I
mean reporting someone for I mean I
don't know there must be some sort of is
it essay possibly it's a very weird like
the thing is you're speaking from you're
speaking from a female point of view
let me ask a question though are we
saying that this person's gone through a
transition or that they're just doesn't
matter yes
so let's let's take it to the extreme
just for this argument
dude chopped off his thing
yeah and as has the whole surgery did
everything looks just like like some
something no you look like women yeah
so so so so
Eddie goes on a date with a girl
blessing don't have that meat in mind
the girl he's taking this girl's out of
my lead she's hot right he takes her
home after the date they hook up
he doesn't know that like she's got the
surgery and everything yeah it's wild
um so is that essay because it's none or
fraud but is it that it's non-consensual
that the person is not who you thought
they were yeah
I hear what you're saying no I'm asking
exactly I'm asking would you say it is
or it isn't
it it is it is but it are you not he
there could be many reasons why not who
you say you are ah just don't give
excuses for that it's not an excuse she
asked me a question
about it right in this moment yeah
it's a very techy situation yeah and I'm
sure what happens a lot that's how
people die seriously I didn't want to
say I'm happy you said it yeah that's
how people die because people get [ __ ]
up like doing that [ __ ] I hope I never
see you again rightly so because that
shouldn't that's why yeah like people
actually die like if people get
themselves into really crazy situations
if if you're gonna not disclose the fact
that you are trans and you are gonna
interact with me and I'm thinking that
you are a woman and then I found out
that you're actually not listen that is
a very messy situation for for a quote
unquote woman to be in that's a
courageous error I'm telling you because
a lot of men will be like what the [ __ ]
is what and you can get yourself into
some serious [ __ ] with that I wonder
what the law is what do you think I
think I think you're right I think you
should just I think they probably should
be disclosing it as well so if they
don't is it a crime
um I don't know I don't know what to say
about that I haven't really got
an answer I don't think it I don't think
they should be done for fraud if I'm
honest I think that's a bit much but um
I feel like that's like because the
other option is great or essay that you
could so say like say if I had a partner
and I was having unprotected sex with
them thinking I was in a committed
relationship but they was cheating
unprotected then then surely that should
be something as well because I'm only
having unprotected sex consensually
thinking it's just us too so if my
partner was having was cheating
unprotected or whatnot then surely that
could be under that as well so so you um
so so you think that a guy lying to
someone about his gender saying that
he's oh no I'm not sure
you think it's similar similar I think
anxiety and about anything to get
something that you know a guy cheated is
I know I think lying about anything
anything where you know there's a chance
that if you tell the truth you're not
going to get what you want then I don't
think you should be doing it no there's
levels alone that's it there's levels
there's levels to everything okay like I
think there's okay
cheating right I I put that but if
you're doing it you're putting someone's
Health at risk okay okay okay so that's
that's wrong right you could argue that
whatever but then then there's there's
not telling someone your gender yeah
this goes can I just say something
before we go into a whole other episode
this is now going into transwise gender
yeah like gender if someone's had a
reassignment then are they this and that
so it's going there's a whole different
ball game okay I'll bring it back uh
yeah sorry I'm only just being conscious
of that yeah exactly that's what I was
just trying to say that's why you
already lost your Instagram
I'll bring it back I've got
um oh basically
um The Guardian was saying it's actually
gone off my phone the guardian was
saying
um that dating apps are more beneficial
from for a certain caliber of men than
they are for women women generally
get benefit from dating apps but there
are certain as we lacked or not as we
say on this on the show the top 20 of
men is beneficial for them
um
as women
do you think that when you were on the
dating app do you think that you were
looking for the same type of man that
every other woman were looking for
I
see what I like it's not really in his
ways everyone's got different tastes you
know what does your ideal Man look like
[Music]
I don't know I wouldn't say a certain
height that what's the minimum height
that you date my height probably I'm
five five so my heart you'd better get
your daily do you how many okay last
last two three X's how tall were they
they um were like five eight five nine
okay so they were both five eight five
nine yeah about that what the um my
first boyfriend was was taller but the
the last two yeah they've been they
haven't been that much taller than me no
like a couple of inches okay but so it
sounds like they're a similar height
yeah but what about saying that what
about being with two that blow it's like
day two what about what about race same
race no mixed they were they both mixed
not like mixed races but it's it's just
a mix that I'm not I'm not a racist so
I'm up for
a lot of racist often oftentimes girls
like will say they don't have a type but
if I look at their exes they kind of
look the same right yeah no I get that
but then I think sometimes you can have
they might have a one-off but like
usually it'll be like this guy like
similar somewhere one off similar
similar well that only certain blokes
make it past the certain stage you know
I get that it's just my I don't know I
think I'm quite varied with that I don't
think you could look at my day in
history and see a pattern if I'm honest
you don't you don't think that women
like the guys that other women want yes
but you don't think we kind of go for
the same guy like if we walk into if we
have 10 guys walk into a room we'll find
the same ones attractive if Eddie walks
into a room right now if Andy walks into
room right now do you think that most of
the women in the room will be looking at
Eddie
as Jackson supposed to a man that
doesn't look like Eddie oh it smells
like yeah
you hear that you hear that hypergamy no
I'm just saying like most of the time
women want uh the guy that other women
want because women essentially like
competition
they that the thing is I think it's it's
not even a conscious thing sometimes it
is but I think sometimes the
subconscious thing I think if if we were
to bring like three other women into
this room right now right
um they would be sizing the ladies up in
this room right they'll be like oh what
is her hair like what is she got makeup
on do you know what I mean like what's
she wearing like women like competition
like that's how they are and the thing
is they're in that competition because
of men
because they're looking generally
looking for the same guy yeah yeah I
think roll automatic calls it
competition anxiety right so in that
situation yeah women will come into the
room and it's like
it's it's a game of like who's gonna be
the Lioness in the room type thing right
but then for the guy
if that same guy walks in with let's say
two attractive women then all the women
start to get curious as to why why is he
with those women yeah and why do they
like the attractive weird what makes
them so attractive and that's when they
start calculating and trying to
understand what this guy's about so
yeah it's very interesting how I
wouldn't behave in those environments do
you think that I'm curious if you see a
guy
um his ex-girlfriend like you're
interested in a guy and you see his
ex-girlfriend was morbidly obese and a
single mother with three kids from three
different dads does that
does that change your opinion on him or
are you equally interested in that
changes my opinion on him because it's
about
choices it's about yeah like who what
sort of level have you been operating at
not in a rude way but who have you
chosen to be with that's not necessarily
just based on aspects but if a man is
willing to go with a woman who's got
several fathers to to her children to me
you're not making the choices that are
what what if he met to me like he might
not have any other option right then do
you need to look at your choices and how
you ended up with that man yeah or is it
that some some guys will end up with
females like it's easier for them
because they like control or power so if
you look at a lot of relationships that
are like unfortunately like abusive in
whatever way whether that's mentally or
physically is a control element where
they'll go with women who are more
vulnerable who don't have that
confidence who are insecure because it's
easier for them to and bigger girls men
like you know we're bigger girls get
what they want out of those women I
think a lot of girls in toxic
relationships are toxic themselves 100
reviews back 100 like I don't I don't
find that it's often like the vulnerable
ones like I I just find that like it's
the equally toxic ones I think
narcissists and there's a lot of studies
on this the narcissists attract
um attract input that and impact yeah so
that's where that comes from if you've
got someone that then there's numerous
studies about this you can look online
about this there's numerous [ __ ] about
this online
so you see when it comes to like the
whole dating app thing
um it's so crazy to me like actually
looking at the whole day map datar and
the way in which human beings interact
um is it easier to portray yourself what
we already know is it easy to portray
yourself as somebody else and when it's
time
to meet that person if you've guys been
dating app because I haven't have you
met somebody from a dating app
and then been like this person is
nothing like what they say so not not
physically I'm talking about the
quote-unquote vibe Vibe I just think
social media in general is all about
perception yeah that perception is king
So people do things to paint a certain
perception of themselves but that may
not necessarily be a reality of the
situation I think when I was when I was
studying a decision in consumer science
they call those a public sphere and a
privacy so now in this digital world
people have multiple
um realities that they can kind of
create for themselves right so there's
there's the digital reality it's like an
avatar it's like an avatar exactly that
so there's a digital reality is that
there's the real world reality right the
digital reality is where you you get the
people on like games like second life
where they've just created this this
fantasy of who they are and what they're
aspiring to be and to some degree they
think that's them and then you meet them
in the real world and it's just it's
nothing like it so the energy in the
vibe is all different
have you ever met a girl that seems
really sweet and then you look at her
Instagram and it's just ass
well I didn't met her in person yeah
better in person you're like oh she
seems so innocent deception changes like
that literally like that and then you
see like her Instagram and it's great
because that's happened to me a couple
of times on the show where a girl come
in I'm like oh she's such a sweet sweet
and then you look at it and then I have
her Instagram like oh my god
seriously which makes you like ask a
question why if you are this innocent
cool chill person
in person why do you feel the need to
show that because people are insecure on
the internet and social media makes
people go into this world where they're
competing with each other and majority
of these people are not even happy a lot
of the people that post certain things
they might not even be in joint they're
just going with the crowd because people
don't want to think outside of the
boxing because they feel like they might
be lonely or they're not with the crowd
The In Crowd or this that the other
they're just following in suit that of
things that other people are doing I
think with women women have this like
from from a biological standpoint this
like kind of group mentality so when
they see other women doing certain
things and getting success off it then
they feel like you know you need to
emulate that to be in this group and
hence the BBL culture hence the BBL
culture makeup blowing up your lips etc
etc so you don't want to be ostracized
from any group and if you see a certain
group of women getting success doing
certain things and you think okay that's
what I need to do to get the man that I
want it's a similar it's the same thing
with what men will say we want natural
women who have natural beauty but in
women will say but you [ __ ] the girl
with the fake bum and the big breath yes
that was a [ __ ] they're not going on
Wi-Fi and and again we say this on a
regular basis there's certain women that
we there's a caliber women that would
work in a caliber woman that would wife
we tell you the caliber women that we'd
wife but you see what we go for in terms
of just quick interactions and you seem
to assume that that is what men want
when they read the thing is right on on
the flip side of that is because the
society in which we live in is a get
is a half sex culture we are living in
the hookup culture we are living in the
hookup generation right and so the
reason why women are getting confused by
that is because because everybody's
hooking up with each other
um and they're seeing the the people
that are getting the attention for the
hookups women are thinking
I need to do that right but generally
human beings are not looking for
anything long-term but women I think
women looking through beer goggles
because it's like big you because to me
what you should be paying attention to
is who the women that are married and
it's not the ones with bbos and blowing
up lips if you look at the women that
are married they're
they're not even like tens they're like
just like I see it this is where I
disagree this is what's confusing to
women and I I understand like from my
point of view that a lot of times the
girls that are married are just bad
wives but I've I've had girls on the
show that are married and I look at
their Instagram and they're thoughting
it up on Instagram and it's like men put
up with a lot of [ __ ] and it's because
men are feminized though no I agree I
agree but I'm saying like there's a lot
of bad like one out of four marriages
are sexless those girls still get a ring
they're sexless I hear that but then
these women don't look like the bbo like
they think the Kim Kardashians
they're not those girls like those are
the girls that men just [ __ ] get rid
of so cool those women exist and they're
doing the madness on Instagram but
they're not the ones who have the the
Cosmetic work done yeah so then would
you say that
um dating app so strictly
for hookup culture I don't know I think
he I think it's got that way but I think
humans are ruining [ __ ] everything
really everything gets taken to an
absolute extreme to where it can't even
be bloody enjoyed I mean look at [ __ ]
lockdown look how quick people were to
turn into absolute idiots but uh it's I
think that's happened with that it's
just too the reason why I say that is
because I read from the guardian right
because the guardian says
um data from outside sources suggests
that most people on dating apps are not
finding lost in relationships or
marriages through these platforms
I think they had good intentions that
they they probably started off with you
know what we're gonna we're gonna add to
this growing digital age and connect
people in ways that have never been
connected before because what it should
do is facilitate conversation and and
actually boost communication but what it
actually does in in connecting people
you're actually separating people at the
same time so what's what's come from
that is that as humans we are
opportunists in whatever we can do for
the men we found a way to have a massive
access to a massive pool of women that
would never would have had access to
before so like if you back in the day
before dating apps if you lived in East
London
the maximum women that you're going to
get around is the women in your area now
whether you live in east south
Hertfordshire Liverpool these women are
now all accessible too so so so now it's
it's just it's open the floodgates for
people to just move frivolously it's too
much Choice isn't it that's the thing
that's why no one's picking or or or
staying because it's just too much for
the women or for the men
um oh I suppose but if you're going on
it
too what do you mean do you think it's
for the men well they're not but they
have too much Choice as well yeah I
think anything online but I'm saying
that it all depends on the app I see uh
50 I see something on line about Tinder
it was only 15 was women I think that's
wild I think it's a small percentage of
men that don't want to settle down I
think most men want a wife and kids yeah
and most men are pretty realistic with
what they can get I don't find that the
more variety men like I don't find that
most men have that much choice
yeah man women have more Choice than men
as you can as you can probably tell like
as I've always said ladies if you were
to walk out this house right now looking
your quote-unquote bummiest you'd still
get attention from me
but do you just think that's because
Eddie was as a biological driver do you
just think that's because men seek sex
so regardless of or do you think there's
something more to that go on Eddie
you've gone after that see I think men
seek sex but at the same time there's a
lot of men who are very realistic in
what it is they're able to attain so
they'll be more than happy to have one
woman he would like
take it K2 and could cater to them and
and they'd be at the game but the
reality is that most men and even from a
historical standpoint didn't get an
opportunity to reproduce so in the
context of a dating app like it
definitely probably favors women more
men would probably want to get more out
of it but they can't we've seen the
stats you know women are swiping 14
whilst minute swiping 67. so if anything
men probably want relationships more
than women do on those apps but they're
not being but are they being clear about
that
maybe like maybe that's what they feel
like but you've seen the male side so
what what do you see
[ __ ]
I've only twice used these sites and
then it's been a one day you should
download it as as a woman and see what
you get don't don't stop that fishing
what do you mean like Rita like research
purposes and just see their [ __ ]
messages you get bombarded with some of
them are that's the other thing I think
what about Max horrible matchmaking I
think that there's dating apps and then
there's matchmaking sites so I know
someone who's trying to develop an app
where it's more matchmaking based so
Harmony yeah but then there's an actual
human who tries to match you to people
who have a similar so it may start with
an online platform but then there's a
human element to it where it's like
right do they have the same values as
you right do you you know when you talk
about what era do they live in are you
going to be able to sustain a
relationship when you're living like on
the opposite side of the world and then
they actually provide you with profiles
or people they think might match with
that's a good idea that's more whereas I
started on the Internet or online
there's actually an element of like back
and forth where it isn't just you're
swiping saying that do you think like
long distance relationships when it
comes to apps are sustainable no hell no
happened to pen power waste of time
literally just sending needs back and
forth on our face I think if you meet
someone say if you met someone on
holiday it's a different situation isn't
it you spend like two weeks together or
whatnot that's a bit different like long
term but to start something long term or
you're not even there it seems a bit
much I think just get rid of dating
let's be honest we need to teach humans
what it means to interact with each
other once again it's money now though
most of them are paid and that's true
but I think we have to look at the root
cause of a lot of these issues and and
I'm always going to go back to this but
I think the spark and the growth in in
single parent mothers and raising Sons
not to be goal getters and have the
ability to go and Court a woman on the
street is just creating so much
negativity in how we interact with each
other because of like like I was taught
literally you go out there and you learn
the hard way right I I would I had to
grow if there was a numbers game me and
my boy would pick a location we're not
leaving to go at least 10 numbers right
and through that you learn how to
communicate with people you learn what
works and what doesn't you learn what
people can interact with and what people
find weird or whatever
rejection and how to face rejection yeah
I think people would be entitled now
like that's actually an important people
get offended if you're not interested
and you're trying to say in a nice way
and it's like oh well you're this anyway
it's like then it's instant like defense
mechanism whereas people used to be able
to face rejection when you could just
talk to people but I think that's right
now Everyone's entitled people can say
whatever they want online and there's no
repercussions but then instant
gratification is part of the internet
because you know
um men I've always said that the
internet has given men access to women
that they would never ever gain access
to tracks in their whole life in general
life like you can go on Instagram find
this woman twerking find this woman who
looks like this and you can interact
with them to some degree and that woman
would never ever give you the time of
day in real life right and so what it is
is that on both the male side and the
female side
um
these apps are giving people a false
sense of reality right and so what
happens is when we enter women a false
sense of reality I I agree with you pal
right I actually agree with you I asked
him the average man his experience on
dating apps he's yeah reality hits him
quit a small percentage and though that
small percentage of men can still kill
it in real life no that that's very true
but I'm just saying when it comes time
to interact with people
um on the real level like you know in in
person I think you know it
people have people take that psychology
from the app and try to juxtapose it in
real life and it doesn't work it doesn't
work so for me
if it doesn't work then why are most
people meeting online now it just
devil's advocate here is this easier
it's literally just the most simplistic
means to an end because for me I I say
this like I'm still far more successful
with women person in person like
um in real interactions and I am on
dating apps like dating apps is just is
a case of covering different bases it's
like different different standards and
like you're because you know YouTube the
numbers game so 40 that guys are swiping
40 of the time because it's a numbers
game so that 14 of females there's bound
to be one that's right yeah so you're
getting volume you know you know what's
interesting about dating apps is we get
more data and more information about
what people want yeah the reality of it
what age do you think when and women and
Peak on dating apps
I'm gonna say 22. for women for women
what do you guys think oh this one is
your must be yeah 24th a month okay what
do you guys think for a man
I think it's later in life because
like 31 31
maybe like later 20s I'm gonna say late
20s for men
tell us
researchers determined that while men's
sexual desirability Peaks at 50.
women starts at 18. and falls from there
for online daters women 18 while men
peak at 50.
that is I mean I'm fool you when I'm
good with that
I'm good without hitting your Peak but
but I'm just and that's the thing that's
the whole thing that gets into the the
argument of
um
younger women like older men
facts and older men like younger women
and so but what happens to the women
that are in that older bracket they get
bitter right checks they get better yeah
they need to touch it because they see
they see the younger girls doing what
they used to do and they demonize the
older guys we're going for younger women
when those are the women going for all
the guys when they were younger correct
because when you because everyone
remembers like you know when you're at
school or college or whatever yeah those
girls that were at College the guys that
would roll up in the the car in the
astross they will always go for the
older guys they always would and then
what would they tell you all right guys
my entertainment
women have always liked older men but in
winter when it flips now and they start
to hit their Peak and they climb that's
when they start demonizing the men oh
well you guys are weird why can't you
finally go your own age right here for
younger girls yeah you was that girl
like 10 years ago why do you guys think
that women tend to shame men for having
standards
hold them bitter what do you guys think
I'm just curious like because
whenever whenever men have a standard
often and I'm not saying every woman
right but oftentimes women shame them
for having it so like we have the body
positivity movement right if guys I
don't like fat chicks
I've got to say I don't wanna I don't
want to date a single mother ah if they
say I don't want to date
ugly girls like anything that they say
they're shamed for
I think it's because we treat men like
trash
okay and we have too much higher
expectation of how they should treat us
and what they should be doing for us and
this and the other but we don't hold
ourselves in the same regard I do think
that men don't get treated correctly and
I think in certain cultures obviously
I'm from
um um from the black community I think
black women get treated black women can
sometimes treat black men like absolute
duh and then it's the same cycle you go
through you know someone who's got a lot
of baby fathers and then she has a son
and then she raises her son to be just
like the dad that she costs it doesn't
make sense like that but it's a very
deep like it's like obviously these are
deep issues that go into life what's
very interesting we talk about that um
when it comes to dating apps like the
the p on dating apps and the people that
at least the women that are least
desired on dating apps happen to be
black women
but do you think that's because sorry
because that when I for example when I
went on Tinder that time it was
saturated with white oh you'll sit this
one out it was saturated with white men
so obviously it's like who's frequent in
these apps
is is that is that a cultural thing so
they were and there are there weren't
many black men on there so and I also
think that in society black women are
not desired why
foreign
apps the most desired woman is the Asian
women
on dating apps they're the ones that are
most desired Asian girls kill it yeah
they can cook better I I wonder if you
if I got left for an Asian chick I would
understand yeah Asian women I would
understand Asian women are most desired
black women at least I think because of
white men are most desired black men are
creeping up there
but Asian men are least desired oh it's
all a Madness yeah I feel that um if you
look at media I'm not not social media
necessarily but media what was portrayed
as beautiful and what has been put like
thrown out there if you look at like
adverts when we were younger and models
and Etc it was like the Slimmer white
blonde Etc so they weren't pushing
through that culture of having you know
having black women as as desired right
and then I think because of certain
things within Black Culture where
women have gone through certain
struggles and they've got you remember
we were talking before on the other
episode about like masculine energies or
right those energies there creates this
this thing where
the women are with strong independent X
Y and Z and men are not finding that
necessarily would you say that men in
general not just black not just white
not just Asian do not find a masculine
woman desirable
I think that men like to have that
element of they're looking after you so
women are nurturing but a man wants to
feel like he's able to take care of you
so if you if you're on a level where
it's like no I don't need you men like
to be needed so I I think that kind of
ties into it I think it's really sad how
black women have been treated and Etc in
terms of Attraction it's it's sort of a
Mad complicated issue I'm mixed so the
mixed experience is a completely
different experience as well everyone
has their own experience you don't count
see that and do you know let me tell you
something
you ask a question yeah being
light-skinned is not always the easiest
thing either because people have sort of
it it was a trend right so it's a
relatively new thing if you look at like
when it was when people were able to
have Multicultural relationships it's
kind of a new generation so then was a
fashion statement so you'd get women who
were like oh I want a light-skinned
child you're not thinking about all the
things that come with having you know a
child that is from a different world who
would say I want a light skin child
I've heard white girls say that right
okay I have yeah like because they think
that Designer babies yeah design a baby
but it's like it's not about that you're
actually bring in another human into
this world yeah so it's like it's not
about what you know how melanated you
are but it's yeah
I have a question for you
um so what do you think about women
shaming men for not having standards
because it's interesting I feel like
you've changed your tune a little bit
since last year ah no not at all we're
just talking about something completely
different okay do you know what I mean
that that's it
um I I personally don't shame anyone for
having standards I don't mean standards
I think you your standards should
reflect how you carry yourself if I
don't drink and I was saying I want a
bloke that doesn't drink that's fair
enough if I was out every week and
getting pissed and I was saying I don't
want to play I want I don't want to blow
the drinks in then it's a double
standard I think everyone should have
standards I don't see the point in that
but so you disagree with women that
shame men for not anyone that is women
men and I know what that so like women
women I'll give you an example women
were shaming Leonardo DiCaprio for only
dating girls under 25. I do think that
is a bit suspect if I'm honest okay okay
you agree okay I think I think there's a
certain age Gap
and it's if it's a the things that
people fall in love I'm not saying every
age Gap is weird I think if you're an
older bloke and you've got a habit of
going with younger girls and I I
personally think sexual preference uh
yeah I do because I think sometimes
there's um a power Dynamic what if it's
the same what if it's a woman going for
a younger oh 100 it's the same thing
it's like that um or what if it's a what
if it's a beautiful woman going for a
rich guy
is she taking advantage of him but is he
only with her because she's beautiful so
it's the same thing isn't it right but
I'm sorry
eye candy yeah that's what I'm saying
but like why why is one shamed and the
other isn't I I think I just said they
were both the same in it no I was I was
sad
for myself I'm saying if a beautiful
woman is with a rich man but you said
that one's okay no I was but I'd imagine
he's probably with her
because she's beautiful that's the way
it is isn't it that men like I think I
think we both want attractive Partners
everyone wants someone they're attracted
to Jesus that is what it is that's just
I know people say but it's just it's
just interesting because you said that
you don't shame anyone for having
standards but you kind of did with oh
with the eyes so that's a different sort
of that's a different sort of make sure
they're over 21. 21 to 25 I think that's
just what so if a 50 year old started
down the 21 year old you think that's
all right yeah well fair enough if he
wants it's fair enough if she's okay
with it I think at 21 you can make your
own like when I was 21 I could make that
decision I wouldn't do it why me
personally as a 50 that that's two
that's a 41 year old man I wouldn't date
a 21 year old that's just me personally
would you find it weird if one of your
mates said do you want to meet month to
go on day in and in walk to 21 year old
I wouldn't find it weird would you be a
little not at all I wouldn't find it
weird why wouldn't you do it because
everyone's different but once ever once
people are of age I'm like you can do
what the hell you want but I'm just
saying for I'm just saying for me as an
individual yeah yeah I couldn't like I'm
just like what do I have in common with
a 21 year old like I I I can't see it
but some 50 year olds just don't care no
right exactly exactly you know I don't
use hot exactly but I see the logic
behind why they wouldn't care though
because um the problem is now is that
when you're of that age if you're dating
women in and around your age there's a
lot of problems there
that the man of that age doesn't
necessarily doesn't want to deal with
I'm not say again I wouldn't do that
myself but I can see why they would if
you're 51 and you're trying to date like
a 35 Plus year old that's a hell of a
lot of baggage a hell of a little bodies
that you've got to take into your life
whereas if you go for the 21 to 25 year
old she's still malleable you know and
they're easily mocked that um just to
say it
younger women are easier to mold easy to
mold to what you want can I just say but
we're these are 50 year olds that are
dating so therefore they've probably
been through right a relationship and
it's had a breakdown so they as you said
they don't want the drama so they're not
they're not necessarily now dating to
get a new wife they've just they've
probably been through a breakup maybe
they've got children they've got that
baggage themselves and they're not
trying to go into it as you said another
baggage relationship so they're looking
for the the fun like the midlife crisis
reliving their youth before they went
through the messy divorce well that's
one of the reasons why you know older
men tend to not deal with women their
age and also tend to not deal with you
know women who have children because
that baggage
speaking from experience
um that baggage as a woman who's got a
child been through certain things in
life
um it's a lot to take on as a man when
you're just a single man who's probably
you know built up built up what he's
built up and is cool when he's
okay living the life the way he lives it
to bring on somebody with so much
baggage is there's there's no benefit to
it but I have a question for the girls
do you think it's more who do you think
has more like emotional baggage is it
them at that age so let's say the boy 51
man and a woman who has more emotional
baggage is it the woman or the man who's
like who's more bitter at that age at 21
not at 20 like at 50 50. he's more bits
it just depends on the person I don't
think you can I'm saying Jim realize it
who's more bitter mental without the cat
being single broken down relationship
but at that age who's more bit on men or
women probably women
why would you say that
because again we're basing it so like
this is a holistic yeah because they may
be more likely if they've had children
to be the one that's had ended up with
the children and had to take that
responsibility the man may be moving out
of the marital home maybe them having to
take over the finances being the single
mom feeling like they've don't have the
options maybe career differences I think
women
are more likely to be watching on the
man as well like what's he doing who's
he now dating men bounce back quicker
but I also think men get really
traumatized as do women but because it's
not widely spoken about we just think
that they're not traumatized I think
you've got a good shot yeah I think when
at that age I suppose if you are single
year I've got kids who've you've had a
long but you know there's there's a lot
to it than just that so if we know that
then why is it a problem because if
you're saying that women are bitter at
them older ages then why is it a problem
when a man goes through when a man
chooses someone younger I say I think
there's a certain part I think from
sometimes as well as women you know it's
men that go younger because they can't
get women their age and I don't think
you can put that down to the women being
bit off
we don't want to wait a minute wait a
minute
I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry you're dating
a younger woman aren't you
um yes I am but
um can you not get women your own age I
can get women of every age tell them
again
what'd you say it's harder to attract
women your age or younger women which
one are easier okay so if if you look at
me just
easy
I can attract generally I can attract
women of all ages
um younger and older okay and that that
is one of the benefits of being a man of
age whereas a woman of age he's
generally going to try and attract men
of her age and if she attracts women if
she attracts men of a younger ages we
know it as well they're looking for
experience
it's not for anything long term okay so
yeah like men have that benefit and it's
one of those things that you know a lot
of women try to shame men for they try
to shame men for say oh you're going
with these young girls like I can
attract as a 41 year old man I can
attract a 50 year old woman
but I can also attract a 21 year old
woman
but the problem is is that when we tell
women these things why don't they take
it on board so I guess be confused
because I've had this conversation with
women my age women that are younger and
I would let them know that listen
this is your Prime use it to the best of
your ability to get the best that you
can attract now but for some strange
reason they think this is my time to
play and have fun and then when they get
older that's when they start to get
that's what the language changes and it
gets bitter and but I I would say that
women
are hard of hearing
yeah they're hard-headed I'm I'm that's
just me is that the Modern Woman
in general are hard-headed like I would
say modern women especially women
generally yeah so it's like
this manosphere space red pill space has
existed for a certain amount of years
and when men in this space have spoken
this way women have said oh he said this
he said that he's they're not listening
and the thing is it's not like we're
saying anything that's quote unquote to
my to my personal thing I I don't think
we're saying anything that's outlandish
no we're all Revolution or revolutionary
we're saying the things that men
actually think but women have been so
used to listening to their girlfriends
like women live in an echo chamber where
they go the echo chamber just their
girlfriends I mean we have a male dating
coach like the Derek Jenks or whatever
his name is dairy Jackson yeah the Steve
Harvey's yeah yeah yeah like and we just
have condition in it even like men they
call their daughters what a princess why
is she a princess average chick yeah
like it's true because
men
she deserves the world why women women
live in an echo chamber with their
girlfriends and with society and that
Society tells them you are the best you
are amazing you that you can do no wrong
right and so that's why when you do the
the on street if you do like an
on-street interview woman are you a 10
yeah I'm a 10. you've done it Pearl
right everyone's a 10. and that's the
crew if you've seen an actual eight nine
or ten you will think twice before you
call yourself right like
if you're a real eight nine or ten
you've been getting paid just for being
hot now if I was to ask Eddie Eddie what
would you rate yourself
I'm also needs 6.5 but my personality
takes me to a seven okay see and the
thing is it's flexing his chest but the
thing is that is something as a man that
we know like we know our level because
you know what when we're around our guys
we know we have a group of guys and we
know the guys that get the girls you
know the guys and we know the guys that
kind of don't get the girls but you know
the guys who get it easy we know the
grafters and the guys are getting
nothing right exactly and so when but
the thing is women also know that but
they don't say it now they lie like when
you ask a girl who's the ugly friend
right my friend my friend oh you didn't
listen he's the ugly friend this is it
like women lie to each other they
constantly lie to each other and this is
why they are able to all of them sit in
a room and say oh yeah I'm a 10. but you
know when you go out on a Friday night
Saturday night you know the ones that
aren't getting the attention
I think you'll do that on purpose they
purposely chill with girls they know
they're more attractive them so that
they keep up more the attention that was
in the 1950s dating advice it was it
looks like 1920s dating advice and it
said you know basically get hotter
friends so you can get their leftover
like women know who the ugly friend is
but they won't tell them that they're
ugly friend do I look good in this dress
no girl you look amazing
don't lie to her
that like that's what we do they just
lie to their friends they always do they
they and the thing is we can speak like
this until we're blue in the face
they're still gonna do it that The
Sisterhood is a thing okay I'm gonna
take a second I'm gonna Read Super yes
please um guys make sure you like the
video the like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams a blessing how many people
we got watching right now one seven one
eight
one nine we have 1 900 people watching
live um so make sure you like the video
we should have at least a thousand likes
in the chat also guys make sure you're
signing up for our memberships we have
four tiers the first gets you to be a
part of the chat the second you get our
behind the scenes Vlogs and our Discord
the third
um you connect with my new Instagram a
on social media I'm just pearly things
one and the fourth tier um you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month a
lot of people use this if they want help
growing on YouTube I got 77 million
views this month so if you guys want
help with that or you know other people
just oh I wouldn't help
[Laughter]
um okay guys let me get to the super
chats okay Shooter McGavin
hi Australia yes dating apps are
affecting relationship it's
relationships it's a form of social
media window shopping there will always
be the thought that they're that their
the thought is they're better it's
appearance based not on character or
personality swipe left or right it's
just a game NSX women get told you're
the prize a man will love you for you
men get told women are the prize work
hard spoil her pay for stuff be
competent protect cook clean respect her
be selfless and romantic very different
illumine illuminated Jacob what about
Latinos what is desirable of a Latino
um a men and women
what would you guys say Latino is that
in the dating app data uh not that I
remember I don't know where they came
actually but Latino women are special
though they are
she said they are
um
90 free toe pay um Pearl
rude Pearl Pearl reads like the kid in
Billy Madison
hello hello
um discount
um Billy hello discount Billy how do you
say her last name eliish Ellis
Hello Discount Billy eilish nice double
talk
um Eamon um Dania I believe with good
reasons that people used to stay
together because the lack of options
everything has literally changed since
the internet and thanks for the variety
of great content Pearl keep it coming
thank you Russ I'm 90 free top hey
um feel free to read my name as oh
um if ladies didn't care about their
friends opinions would they have found
true love already
um watch how the ladies flip the
question love you Pearl stranger 58
majority of the time dating apps are a
platform for women to window shop for
wallets Bad Boys projects and attention
for guys it's simply the booty
um was a feel free to name my name feel
free to read my name as woj's at wash by
the way hi Eddie thanks for ignoring my
Instagram when I asked about the podcast
my bad message me again
uh dating apps uh dating apps did not
ruin modern dating it's the Western
society that ruined women I'm six three
blonde blue eyes lad in the UK I get Max
of three matches per month when I use
Tinder in Poland I get 120 matches in
three days you need to go to Poland bro
serious that's what that's what um
um there is a guy I did a reaction with
the passport Bros you went to Brazil
yeah and he's having a great time I'm
telling you the women are different yeah
listen if I go to Thailand I'll clean up
outside and then sue everyone because
they wonder who they said they were true
lady boys
and the lead attorney
um salute Pearl
s Lead attorneys lead attorneys in here
pick up the leader Teddy and that's
that's everyone okay
um no I'm sorry there's one more I'm
sorry
um you I assume everybody lies as a
baseline Bible truth and actions speak
louder than words I don't have social
media and can say from the outside
looking at its nightmarish it's easy to
lie that's why I admire you for telling
the truth
right
um we have a video before we uh before
we get going
um
I'm gonna play it and see what you guys
think uh blessing have you got that
ready for us
yeah see what you guys think I'm still
wondering why so many girls are single
let me give you an example so my best
friend and I went out over the weekend
for her birthday and she was talking to
this guy from one of the dating apps I
think hinge so she's a really sweet girl
and not really into being mean but I'm a
bad [ __ ] and I don't let men walk all
over women so let me first just give you
a little bit of background she has never
met this man before and they've probably
only been talking maybe three or four
days so he was talking to her about
meeting us out on the night out um
Tobias drinks and to get to know her
while she's around her friends so it was
a little less awkward so he texts her
maybe 15 minutes later after telling her
he was gonna meet us out and is like
actually I'm not just I'm just not
feeling too well could you actually come
to my place right now I bought us a
bottle of wine and she was like um no
like this is weird I'm out with my
friends like why is he being like that
so I was like okay give me the phone let
me text him and I text him back and I
said I'm just not the type of girl to
just come over and [ __ ] on the first
date I'm more of a wine and dine type of
girl and he said I know that I said then
whine and dine me first LOL and he said
I didn't even think you were spending
the night I legit thought you were just
enjoying a glass of wine just to talk
and stuff okay then why wait until
another night so I said I told you I was
going out with my friends thought you
were meeting us guess another time then
and he said I just had a hectic week I
wanted to spend the night in is all I
was gonna come over
um to high Banks but you didn't text me
that you were out even though she
definitely did so anyway I just liked
the message and I was like okay let's
just make it the end of that but we
can't do that with men obviously so he
texts back and says I now see why you're
25 and single and liked his own message
then continues to send all of these
messages you can pause the read but
really they all say the same thing and
then even more
it even says like hell I'll show up in
10 where are you at so I can come out
boy what and then ended it with just
have a good night I hope it's fun she
has never met this man before and he
sent her 30 messages
are you okay does that sound okay this
is stocky Behavior this is weird
Behavior this is why women are still
single not because we can't get a man
but because we don't want y'all if
you're still yeah but you can't get the
men that you want so plus is is women
um
my question is though after that does do
dating apps make people feel entitled to
people 100 yeah
what it does is it grants you access to
someone's attention so once you're
exchanging your attention do you feel
intact to that person's attention let
the video showed he didn't know that
girl from when from anyway but for some
reason he felt entitled to drop all
those messages right
wet on I guarantee he took a lot from
his mum no dad's teaching his son to
move like that come on Lola you're like
you're itching to say something wrong
that was just made me laugh because I
kind of agree yeah I think that over
access to people even like for me over
access in general so I don't go on my
phone too much I'm sometimes I'm more
time in sunlight don't disturb I'm not
on social media all the time if someone
sends me a message I'm well within my
right to not reply until I'm ready to
talk to the person and I my friends
people that know me know that that's how
I move so they're not offended but
because people we've in this generation
where we are giving instant access to
everything we're not you see if like I
want to actually talk to someone I don't
want to quickly reply while I'm in the
middle of doing something else I'd
rather wait until I have time right then
then be like rushing around and then we
that's why people are constantly in
their phones getting confused not not
interacting and that goes back to us not
interacting in person because we're
stuck having 20 different conversations
and we're not even present in the moment
that we're in so for me I think yeah
that over access and entitlement of you
have to immediately respond or that's
the reason why when I went on hinge I
got overwhelmed and I I was on hinge for
24 hours thought the profile idea was
cool I wasn't really in it for myself
again a friend that said look try and go
on there and I thought you know what
I've got nothing to lose I'll try
something new if it's not for me it's
not for me but then the messages coming
through and it was just overwhelming for
me and I was like this is actually too
much so I just canceled it so given over
access to yourself and in terms of
dating apps I've had friends where
they've been talking to a guy and then
when it's like actually I don't want to
meet you the person turns nasty and it's
like why are you turning nasty like
you're entitled to say actually you're
not for me and not waste a person's time
but people just take things defensively
I've had that where like because I'm on
social media people that don't know me
feel like they know me yes and so it's
like maybe they'll have seen my show or
maybe and like they'll kind of treat me
a certain way when they've never even
talked to me in real life and it's
interesting because it's like the way
they'll talk to you is like as if they
know you and I'm like I don't know who
you are you know and you know it's
interesting pill right they'll send you
a message
starts off like hey how you doing I hate
it and you don't and you don't message
back and you don't even know they've
messaged you right and then the longer
get mad and then they start getting mad
and I'm just or they call you out in the
comments for not replying to you yeah
listen message me again
and the thing is I think that
entitlement
when it comes to like social media is
one of the reasons why up you know why
I've bought this um this subject up
because when we are interacting with
people like this in general like we
don't I don't feel entitled to anybody's
attention generally if I interact with
them but social media and you know
dating apps make you actually feel
entitled if you're interested in the
person because I think we feel that way
we were not interested what happens when
you're interested in a female or a
female's interested in a guy and we all
know how often we are all on our phones
right so I feel like it's hard for
people to say you don't get irritated
and you know songs with their phone and
they choose not to read and I think
that's something that social media is
create this that that sort of anxiety
online but not for you it's like yeah
I'm online but not for you is that why
don't you reply to me when I know you
got your phone next to you because it's
because you are yeah what's that who are
you if you like for example if my mother
and calls me God knows if I don't answer
she's like what's going on she calls me
again I'm gonna answer any scenario and
be like do you see what I mean because
that's my mum so she's she can have in
access to me if it's your partner they
get Priority Access but I think it's not
anything I feel like men get turret men
get more Soul territory with that and
this is one of the things I always tell
men to just chill the [ __ ] out sometimes
like
men get territorial with women that they
don't know it's so crazy that I've not
like I'm just like she's not your girl
bro because there's too many ways to see
what a person is doing because it's that
cool you can see who feeds your story
you can see when someone's online you
can see someone's got your message so
it's like if I it's I think the
perception in a lot of guys heads is
that again there's that level of
entitlement that they're not self-aware
enough to understand that you're not
entitled to my time but then it's a case
of all right I've given you my time
whether you like it or not and then I
can see everything else we're doing
including looking at my story do you get
irritated when someone looks at your
story but they don't reply to your
message I don't care because I do the
same thing to everyone else
I'm not too fast because my thing is
this is like when your social media is
at a level where you're constantly
getting messages you switch off so like
for me if I see like three or more
messages no one's getting a reply no
until I'm ready to take it one by one
right and it's going to be like one
every other hour because I'm talking
about things and I might still post a
story I might still post content I'm
just not replying to you because I'm
doing other things so let me ask you a
question already as a man like that
because sometimes I feel like that
um comes into real life so you see if
you're in a club or a bar setting right
and
you buy a woman a drink do you feel like
she's entitled to give you her attention
for the rest of the night no right no
that's exactly why I never accept drinks
I always say it to my it's no yeah
because you get some blokes that think
because you've said yes then that's it
do you think do you think you should
only accept a drink if you're interested
in the guy yes
um yeah I could see why some women view
it like if they're offering just take it
do you see what I mean because that's
not just with men that's just in general
like but I'm not gonna laugh he's dumb
enough to buy you a drink without
exactly that any sort of reason behind
it then finesse's money like that's
another thing is but the consequences of
that if that means I've got to spend the
night avoiding him then I don't want to
do it so I'll just say no I agree with
you I would
I just feel like you shouldn't accept
things from people you're not interested
in right I agree you know I I think like
finessing like sure you could go that
way but it's just better to avoid this
is not definitely it's bad to avoid
abundance thinking if the guys in dumb
enough to want to see I understand
for me again it goes back to you
obviously what I call source and knowing
how to quote and talk to a woman but for
me I'm only ever buying you a drink if
the conversation is off that nature
leading to that like I'm not gonna buy a
drink as a way to court you I think if
you don't have an opening line exactly
can I get you a drink if we're having a
great conversation
and you know your drinks running low and
we're still talking by all means how
often would you like a drink like that's
like because we're having a great
conversation it's not a chat up line of
mine you know what I mean so like if a
girl takes that drink I've had an
interaction that's worthy of me buying
her a drinks off if she goes away for
the night I'm good because I've had a
great conversation yeah but that's it
but the thing is is like
like Pearl was saying like this is my
advice to women don't accept drinks from
men that you're not trying that you
don't find attractive that you're not
trying to take it at another place with
because you just never know like and
it's the same thing with dates I'm like
why do you want to waste your time
exactly you only have so much free time
especially like when we're yeah like
when we're young and stuff why would you
want to go on a date with someone you're
not attracted to because women go on
dates now with men just to eat for the
experience but that's again because
they're living in this social media and
reality where they're doing they're
going on dates of people yeah they're
taking they wanted take a picture of the
meal they want to do this and then post
on socials like they live in the High
Life yes but that's nonsense as well
because who goes on a first date and
starts taking photos of do you see what
I mean but everyone's trying to get I'm
not gonna I hate when women take
pictures of photos
yeah
the pictures of food it's like the food
just came you're like and there's a lot
I just want to eat
what the hell I see girls do those tick
tocks and oh my God I saw this one girl
and it was the first date and the [ __ ]
was tick-tocking it yeah she was like
putting on the video and I'm like girl
what are you doing I still think that's
on the guy though like come on like
don't listen don't let a girl get away
with that do you know what I mean but
you know what if I'm being real you your
Viewpoint makes sense because at the end
of the day we've got to seek the best
outcome to situations and the best
outcome to a situation where a guy is
making herself entitled to your time
it's best not to accept it for the best
outcome for yourself yes because you
will get women who do complain about oh
he didn't leave me alone all night
because he spent money on you yeah and I
equate money to time you worked for that
money which is time lost you can't you
call you can get money back but you
can't get time back 100 so if I'm giving
you that time then realistically I I
should be able to expect that you give
me time back as a result of that so
women it's just to use them so women
stop accepting drinks what about the
girls that go to men's tables then the
same thing stop go into a man's table
right I I listen I've been in the when I
when I was in the clubs right
um I've seen women like at a man's table
like taking all the champagne all of
that kind of stuff helping themselves
today helping themselves and it's like
what at the end of the night what is
going on because that guy is speaking as
man he's thinking I'm spreading cheeks
he's thinking I've spent all this money
something's going down like what the
hell and women are literally there's so
many women out there like I'm just gonna
take his drinks don't do it
but you know what always be girls
pretend like it's innocent oh I was
having a good time it was just a bit of
fun is that wait what Stop Believing
women man like I just don't understand I
just I feel uncomfortable accepting
drinks and even like free anything from
someone I'm not attracted to because you
got money moscale are broke that's why
I was breaking in that coin I mean girls
step out with five pounds I know no way
to get home
no but it's true like I've seen like
Street interviews and women have been
like men have said to women oh when you
go out for a night
do you pay for your own drinks we'll be
like no I don't pay for my own yo come
on I don't know how they're getting home
right they know they will make it home
it is not that's nuts and the thing is
if if you have that mentality understand
that there are men out there if you if
you are going out not knowing how you're
getting home there are men out there
going out thinking I'm gonna smash
something tonight do you know I'm like I
don't know alcohol's involved and
alcoholism it's the whole thing but yeah
um we've run
it's like what midnight or past midnight
um yeah let's let's do um let's do final
thoughts guys thank you all for coming
though
um Eddie let's start with you bro
final thoughts on the on the subject of
uh dating apps
to be honest if if what you seek is
long-term relationships then dating apps
probably aren't the best place
to go and search for it I think build up
yourself as an individual
build up your self-awareness build up
your communication skills learn to be
comfortable with being uncomfortable
because that's the only place that
you're gonna grow a lot of people don't
understand that Comfort doesn't lead
anything positive in the long run so if
you're looking for the woman or a
woman's looking for the guy learn to be
uncomfortable and thrive in those
situations
other than that
obviously I'll probably be back again
but
if you want to see more of my stuff I'm
on um at the domino effect my Instagram
is who's underscore Eddie underscore
give me a shot if you want to come in
the show shout me as well I will reply
when I can
um
Eddie's a recruiter at it
um yeah final thoughts I would agree
with what Eddie said If you're looking
for long-term stability husband and wife
may not be the right uh end goal
um I think try and go out and talk to
some humans everyone in every capacity
all of this we're only communicating
online and then you might even see
someone online you've spoken to and then
when you meet them in person they can't
even say hello to you do you know what
get Hobbies get Hobbies go out and do
your things with those hobbies and then
you'll meet people who are interested in
the same things as you might share the
same values Etc try and do things a
little bit more naturally
um don't consume all your time in the
internet age that's my copy and pasting
messages to everyone yeah don't be doing
all that this world um and you can find
me at Lola underscore Rose Blanc yeah on
Instagram thank you um yeah similar
really if if you want to do it do it but
if you're going into it looking
something serious then probably not the
best and as well it's a lot of
validation I think that with that apps
and social media in general I only seek
validation from people I actually
respect so you know if you're if you're
putting yourself online to get all this
attention then you probably should
look deeper into that personally cool
um I'd say before I go
um follow me on my social medias follow
me on Instagram right almost to 100K I'm
at like seven like nearly 80k or YouTube
guys this is nonsense we got we got 650k
over here go subscribe go subscribe it's
in the description you get get this man
to 100K where was my energy
no seriously go subscribe to my my
YouTube uh Sarah Garvey and on Instagram
I'm actually under the black opinion
because I'm not allowed to be on
Instagram just like Pearl I've been
banned twice on Instagram
I came back as the black opinion right
on Instagram so yeah go subscribe to me
over there and also just before I finish
if you have watched tell them two or
more of all videos hello and you have
not subscribed
then we have what pal beef what we got
beef exactly so go do that right now
Pearl you close it out all right guys
um a couple things like we have a couple
super chats I'm gonna read so Dash token
at 18 you can still convince her to use
a washcloth before she runs her skin via
makeup and sun damage older men have
something to offer younger women or
offer youngers don't
um beaten this man's user name is beaten
cheeks
I don't have any social media presence
and I refuse to use the dating apps and
very old-fashioned by approaching women
and it works better the way it and it
works better the way than that way when
women least expect it maybe we should
teach men to do this approach more to
kill off the egos of women who are fours
um Peter Rogers thank you for the Super
Chat I'm gonna refresh it one more time
just to make sure no one else sent
anything guys like the video on your way
out a like is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
videos on top of that guys a couple
announcements
the first being that we have two clips
channels the first is Pearl daily and
the second is just Pearl eclipse make
sure you subscribe to both the links are
in the description also guys we have
four um different membership tiers the
first lets you be a part of the live
chat the second Discord and blogs third
connect with me on social media the
fourth
um a one-on-one call with me once a
month on top of that guys go follow my
new Instagram I got I have to start from
the ground up so just pearly things
started from the bottom now we're here
and go go subscribe to my fifth and
sixth Tick Tock just pearly things five
and just pearly things six
um thank you for 650k you guys make this
possible I appreciate you all so much I
am blown away that we have grown this
fast this guy has been like six seven
months but I was here from the beginning
yeah he was who is your problem how was
heard from the job
you were your second episode right
second episode
uh like the video on your way